[Musique]
mais passé puisque je me couche tard
joeuf ça il faut bien dormi un peu tabac
du coin d'approvisionnement cigarette
puis revue de la presse
je rend super g fait lecture des
journaux et puis je commencerais à ne
rien [ __ ]
ça m'occupe perdre du temps se veut qu
de trois heures à la place que tenait
mon chien bon alors si c'est chez moi je
pense que c'est un sitting room salle de
musique board est amusé à y aller piano
ses pianos électriques et classique du
sommet
bâtie chansons qui m'ont donné une
certaine notoriété
magnéto aissi ordonnance des objets ça
devient 2 et sont les retombées de mes
études d'architecturé de peinture tout
état désordre apparent n'en fait de
calculer sur des rythmiques particulière
ici déjà comme un des courts sol jamais
de jamais de parallèle c'est à dire
c'est pas possible ça s'applique aussi
tous ces enfants tu rigoles de deux
papes lui devenir un
ça j'ai félix le chat retrouvé à los
angeles
que deviennent les acheter les taches de
couleurs tout noir et blanc et acier
verre
il ya quelques taches de sang comme ces
petits singes marais qui les lie siens
du reggae
parce que c'est mignon mais j'allais me
we 4 ans
voilà l'élément jeunesse dans la maison
cette c3 fini dit et je suis sûr qu'ils
n'ont pas montré franchement pas les
idées recettes mondiales à zilina qui
s'était vidée pour les jeunes et une mer
très maternelle mais très copines aussi
et moi je tiens pour gueuler mais quand
je suis un peu pété je suis clown les
amuse beaucoup
ça c'est ce côté quoi qu'on ne connaît
pas de moi un secret c'est le fait des
pitreries je vais les grimaces je mets
du rouge à lèvres j'aime les enfants
autrement beaucoup de rigueur
enfin ce fait dire ancienne école jeter
quand j'étais petit
[Applaudissements]
bon
l'enjeu n'est pas seulement une maman
est une actrice de cinéma c'est
chanteuse est d'abord acté jeudi à
madrid pour aller voir un producteur
soit un film à gros budget alors c'est
toujours des merdes et djenné - pour
jamais ce qu'ils étaient dix jours
d'absence en dix ans
et vers delhi
rappel
suite aux destinées des mâchoires
chaleur
et si aéré
l'espagne
ce rythme ça va rires lors discute
quelle heure
après ce soir
oui
allez en faire
pour des gares et aux meilleurs ici
c'est la bibliothèque premier étage et
c'est un peu de musique mais simplement
d des bouquins stacy j'ai créé mon livre
par des bouquins bon livre a ensuite pu
suivre le dessus depuis six sept ans du
très couru sur la sur la forme de
bouquins et je suis ici au préfet un
parent préférentiels à rebours de
huysmans et là bas aussi histoire du
surréalisme dunhill de forêt
journal de l'année de la peste
benjamin constant r un mouillage sur ce
bout de l'air et puis des des traités 2
du précis de pathologies médicales
parcours en héros est un état malade 1
alors on était jeté un coup de
[Musique]
sokolov une magnifique la de nice tente
scarface anthropométrie judiciaire est
retombé de dada des enfants rechange ça
les amuse et puis saisissent tommy lee
rare que je suis des contacts seul avec
quelle est leur étoile tout à fait flat
et j'ai rien anglais tuvalu voisin
pourquoi ces bons vieux carré d'agneau
pour 2 pers
vous êtes 2 2
trop cher juste évoqué les cas l'air
à l'uqtr décidé vous a pas couché ses
caisses en gros ce qu'est ce que c'est
un truc tir aux enfants save the king
james lewis thing
on a tête de juhasz et légumes moitié
mec comme j'ai dit dans mon disque salut
team a espionné sais que tu aimes
sculptures de claude lalanne
pour moi c'est un geste héroïque genre
gladiateurs romains
[Applaudissements]
le
ces disques il après ces fameuses
amazones ont fait sortir vous il compose
et ce à deux harmonies de ma chère
[Musique]
silence puisque 1,18 me sentir je
réécoute parfois jusqu'à saturation paie
plus jamais
[Musique]